lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
reflexionar un poco más acerca de qué es
lo que hacen las funciones y después
platicar acerca de las funciones
inversas déjame iniciar con una función
sencilla voy a tomar la función y es
igual a efe de x que es igual a 2 x + 4
2 x + 4
a esta función yo le puedo meter ciertos
valores para x por ejemplo si le pongo f
efe de 2 entonces debemos sustituir 2 de
este lado y me quedaría que es igual a 2
x 2 + 4 2 por dos es cuatro y si sumamos
4 nos da 8 de manera similar si le pongo
3 me quedaría que f de 3 es igual a 2 x
y ahora hay que cambiarla x por 3 serían
2 x 3 + 4 2 por 13 64 es igual a 10
entonces aquí tenemos dos valores de la
función f de 12 es igual a 8 y f de 3 es
igual a 10 pero esto lo podemos ver de
una forma un poco más abstracta como
sigue como que hay algunos valores como
2 y 3 que pueden entrar en la función y
que de ahí nos dan algunos otros valores
voy a hacer un dibujo de este lado a la
izquierda voy a poner los valores que
pueden entrar ene efe los valores o los
números en los cuales podemos evaluar
efe a ese conjunto de valores se le
conoce como el dominio
dominio de la función entonces en este
dominio está por ejemplo el 2
voy a poner por aquí el 2 o bien el 3
por aquí está el 3 y en realidad está
cualquier número real verdad aquí
podemos poner cualquier número real y no
hay ningún problema entonces el dominio
serían todos los números reales solo que
lo estoy dibujando aquí así de una
manera acotada para que sea más fácil
visualizarlo muy bien entonces tenemos
estos valores que pueden entrar en la
función y a cambio la función nos
regresa otros valores como el 8 y el 10
esos otros valores los voy a pintar a la
derecha entonces aquí tenemos otro
conjunto de valores
que se llama el rango de la función del
rango
de la función que son aquellos valores
que podemos alcanzar aplicando la
función f a elementos de su dominio por
ejemplo aquí tenemos el 8 voy a poner
por aquí el 8 por aquí tenemos el 10 y
tenemos otros cuantos más y podemos
dibujar algunas flechas para indicar
cómo cómo se aplica la función f o como
f relaciona elementos del dominio con
elementos del rango por ejemplo como f 2
es igual a 8 podemos dibujar una flecha
de aquí para acá más o menos así
y decir que 8 es igual a efe de dos
dedos otra forma de escribirlo es que f
efe
manda el 2 al 8 al 8 y de manera similar
podemos trazar una línea por acá que me
queda un poco chueca la voy a trazar un
poco mas derechita una línea por acá que
indica que el 3 se va al 10 es decir 10
es igual es igual a efe de 3 o también
lo podemos poner como que f manda
del 3 al 10 al 10 muy bien ahora la
pregunta aquí sería la siguiente será
posible regresar de los valores del
rango a los valores del dominio es decir
existirá alguna función que nos mande el
8 al 2 déjame llamarle a ese a esa
función efe a la menos 1 lo voy a poner
aquí pero ahorita lo lo pongo sobre el
dibujo a esa función si es que existe la
vamos a llamar efe a la menos uno
entonces me estoy preguntando si puedo
empezar en el 8 y regresarme al 2 china
lo mejor debería irme por aquí a bajit o
algo así entonces quiero saber si puedo
empezar en el 8 y de ahí irme al 2
si hay una función efe a la menos 1 que
lo que haga es mandar el 8 al 2 pero no
sólo eso sino que también más del 10 al
3 entonces voy a hacerle así que mande
el 10 al 3
entonces vamos a pensar que esta función
efe a la menos uno manda el 10
al 3 la pregunta es existirá esta
función bueno en este caso si hasta
ahorita todo ha sido muy abstracto pero
ahorita que haga un ejemplo vas a ver
que todo es más claro entonces la
respuesta es que si existe esta función
y vamos a encontrar esa función
despejando equis y poniéndolo en
términos de ella déjame hacer eso voy a
poner una vez más aquí que ya que es
igual a 2 x 2
2 x + 4 y lo que vamos a hacer es
despejar a x entonces voy a restar 4 de
ambos lados me queda que y menos 4 es
igual a 2x y ahora voy a dividir entre 2
me queda que medios menos 2 es igual es
igual a x voy a reescribir esto un poco
voy a voltear esto para que se vea un
poco mejor
entonces me queda que x es igual a un
medio de y menos -2 ok entonces se
observa que estoy haciendo lo que estoy
haciendo es poner a x ahora en términos
de y entonces ahora esto lo que nos hace
o lo que nos da es una función en
términos de i y eso es exactamente lo
que queremos nosotros lo que queremos
hacer es una función que tome valores en
el rango valores de g y que nos lo
regrese a valores en el dominio valores
en x y justo está justo está sucediendo
esto aquí verdad si tenemos un valor
un valor x bueno pues a esta expresión
la podemos pensar ahora como una función
como una cosa de este estilo déjame
tomar otro color del estilo efe al menos
uno efe al menos uno de que es igual a
un medio medio de menos dos un medio de
menos dos vale bueno entonces lo que
estamos haciendo es lo que hicimos para
encontrar este esta efe al menos uno de
iu es poner igual a 2 x 4 despejar la x
en términos de i y simplemente llamar
efe al menos 1 deje a esta expresión de
acá va sin embargo pues esta es una
expresión de una función y aquí tenemos
una variable que podemos cambiar por
cualquier cosa la podemos cambiar por a
por x por r o por lo que sea entonces
déjame cambiarla por equis para que se
vea un poco más como una función nos
quedaría que f
halal -1 de x es igual a un medio de x
menos 2 - 2 y listo esta de aquí sería
la función inversa es la función que nos
permite pasar del rango hacia el dominio
si de 2 nos fuimos a 8 nos permite
regresar de 8 a 2 y de 3 nos fuimos a 10
nos permite regresar de 10 a 3 vale para
hacerla simplemente tomamos la expresión
ye igual a 2 x + 4 despejamos x
despejamos x y luego simplemente
intercambiamos el papel de la ye y la x
yo creo que se puede decir así bueno
ahora una pregunta interesante es qué
sucede si gráfica moss al mismo tiempo
una función
efe y su inversa déjame hacer un pequeño
dibujo para ver qué sucedería en este
caso en los próximos vídeos vamos a ver
muchos más ejemplos pero ahorita nada
más nada más va a ser un ejemplo rápido
sale entonces aquí tenemos el eje x por
acá tenemos el eje
el eje y lo que voy a hacer es graficar
fx
efe al menos 1 de x estás acá las dos
son rectas entonces podemos graficar las
fácilmente si tenemos fx observemos que
la intersección en el eje y es igual a 4
entonces sería 1234 cortaría por acá y
la pendiente es 2 entonces se vería más
o menos así déjame ver más o menos cómo
así
sale entonces esa de ahí sería la
gráfica de ye igual a fx
y por otro lado cómo se vería la gráfica
de dfa la menos 1 de x df inversa de x
bueno pues ahora su intersección en el
eje y es igual a menos 2 la voy a poner
en color rosa menos 1 - 2
muy bien ok y tenemos que su pendiente
es un medio entonces ahora estaría un
poco más acostada verdad se vería más o
menos algo así algo como de este estilo
así
ok y la pregunta es bueno déjame ponerle
antes de preguntar le voy a poner que es
igual a efe al menos 1 de equis y ahora
si la pregunta es cómo están
relacionadas estas dos rectas bueno pues
parece ser que una es la reflejada de la
otra verdad o sea parecería que una está
reflejada con respecto a la otra pero
con respecto a que o con respecto a qué
recta bueno pues para que las cosas sean
mucho más claras déjame dibujar la
gráfica de la función y igual a x
igual a x me voy a poner punteada
entonces es es una cosa que viene por
aquí abajo tiene pendiente uno pasa por
el 0 0 y sigue creciendo así con
pendiente 1 entonces esta es la gráfica
de ye igual a x
bueno pues precisamente la gráfica de la
función inversa df a la menos 1 de x es
el reflejado de la gráfica de la función
con respecto a la línea igual a equis y
eso se puede pensar de la siguiente
manera lo que está lo que hicimos para
obtener efe al menos uno de x es
despejar x en términos de ley y luego
intercambiar los papeles de xy de i y
justo justo reflejar con respecto a la
recta igual a x es cambiar los papeles
de xy de y por ejemplo si teníamos x
igual a cero nos queda que es igual a 4
es más lo podemos marcar aquí si tenemos
aquí en el dominio el 0 eso a través de
la función nos lleva
nos lleva a 44 esto de aquí es igual a
efe de 0
pero si empezamos con 4 y aplicamos la
inversa
eso nos regresa déjame tomar esta
herramienta para hacer líneas un poco
más derechistas esto nos regresa a 0 a 0
vale entonces esto esto manda a 4 a 0 la
inversa manda 4 a 0 entonces justo
estamos intercambiando los papeles de xy
deje de intercambiar papeles de xy de es
reflejar con respecto a esta recta esto
nos cambia el eje x en el eje y entonces
nos cambia el mundo de las x al mundo de
las 10 muy bien entonces esto es un poco
de la intuición que está que está dentro
de las funciones y de las funciones
inversas aquí simplemente hicimos un
pequeño ejemplo pero en los siguientes
vídeos vamos a ver varios ejercicios
para que después tú puedas resolver los
problemas de funciones inversas por tu
cuenta